Let's pray together over day 12.
I realize that there may be some things in your life that make it
difficult to find space and time to pray.
Today, I'm watching one of my seven children as he plays
in the room where I'm praying. In case there are
distractions in your life, let me just encourage you
to go ahead and seek the Lord over top of and in
spite of those distractions, because the Lord understands,
and He hears, and He knows. Let's pray together.
Father, your Word tells me
that the heart is deceitful above all things
and beyond cure. There is no medicine on earth,
there's no treatment on earth that can cure the problems of my heart.
The truth is I can't even see them without the illuminating power of your
Spirit.
So Lord, I pray that you would look
and search like David said, search out in me all
those areas that may be unlike you.
I pray, Lord, that you would shine your light, the light of knowledge, the light of
the Holy Spirit, and that you would illuminate to me
all that is in my heart, Lord. I want to see it. I want to see it with clarity.
Lord, I repent of holding you by the power
of my own stubborn self-will, holding you out of
your rightful sanctifying place in all these areas of my
life.
Lord, let me see my own self-admiration.
Let me see my own self-interest and
self-righteousness. Oh Lord, when others do me wrong,
I get self-piteous. Help me,
Lord, to be able to see that, to be able to see the ways in which I make space
for my own self, my self-indulgence and self-preservation.
Oh God, help me to see my own
self-sufficiency.
Lord, if you don't display this to me through the power of your Spirit,
I'll never be able to see it, and I'll never be able to solve it on my
own.
Lord, you can cure the incurable disease of the heart.
Do it for me, please. I pray in Jesus' name.
Now let's continue to pray together as you use your own words to seek
the Lord and what He's saying and talking to you about.